the sharing economy is turning consumers
into entrepreneurs at the top of a
smartphone but should online platforms
such as Airbnb uber and delivery would
be treated like traditional companies
when it comes to paying taxes hiring
workers or ensuring health and safety
standards and should the EU step in to
set the rules of the new game italian
MEP Nicola don t think so plataforma
estan cambiando Nostra Vita Activa keen
on a few Giovanni simo home ma na un
motivo digital yo penso che hanno
facility no mortal consummatory Linda
deleted most easy breezy and kyo donezo
abbastanza regalame delicata former
alcuni sir busy yo penso che dovrei mo
farsi k y yo paratore professionally
delhi ponnu me a holla Ballas eva debe
ver el asesor a NGO di quelli che sono
operatory delhi columbia traditional
levin so van amento debe ser feito que
puede que son yo operatory known
professionally k envision okuno or ODI
beso so no y con sumotori k off-road
ac/dc Atlantic Ocean Midori so what can
I lawmakers dinner yo credo che oggi
amiamo lucchese ohne dich Frei re o
sistema de Rivoli que facil eita y con
sumotori michaela tutela AK li Ren de
PUE 40 makato me puedo empezar novica
mia credo che sia uno de uno de pont
essencial vida suited our eletrobras
revealed a very unapproachable
EV t amo di creare ven Toto approach' al
economy adela collaborazione a diverse
Europa cream o people o campo di r a
goalie santosh Luella con una holliger
atiba posa sloop RC home forza in europa
es el uno de moto ly tran Adele
appreciated in the paparazzi